hello everyone and welcome to round 2 of
the 2013 World Chess Championship match
between Vishwanathan Anand and the
Magnus Carlsen
I don't think I've mentioned it in my
previous video but the format of the
match is 12 games so if either unloved
or Carlsen wins at least 6 and 1/2
points so if let's say the first seems
six games Causton wins and then one game
is drawn then immediately Causton
becomes the next champion so they don't
need to play all of the twelve but if
there is a tie after all of the twelve
games have been played then under does
not keep his World Championship title
rather a series of rapid and blitz games
will be played to determine the new
champion so that's just something I
wanted to mention and as usual after
every video there will be a link to the
press conference of this round and also
a link to some of the photos that we
won't show in the video so let's check
out some of the photos from this round
and the first one is a really
interesting one so let's see it here it
is as you can see Carson has soda
bottles with his name on them it's not
that he has one he has several so here
is here are three that we know of but
there are there are sure to be more so
they're very interesting then we have a
nice photo of Carson and Anand this is a
photo before round two started as you
can see they're not really interested in
starting a conversation or anything as
they are ready for war just waiting for
the rug to start and you know to again
get on with it here we have a very nice
photo
it's a photo from only the first move
has been made you can see a4 and c6 on
the board so the kurakin will be played
and you can see there are so many
photographers behind the glass wall and
it's interesting with so many
photographers who are there are so few
photos from the from the event in
question here a nice close-up of magnus
carlsen and also a nice close-up of
fishing and we do have one other photo
what that one will have to wait until
the end of the
game so let's see it Anand opens with
efore and calls and chooses see sex is
the caro-kann defense we have d4 d5
Knight to c3 D captures Knight captures
and Bishop to a5 now the classical
variation of the caro-kann and night to
g3 attacking the bishop bishop to g6 and
now h for the the most classical
variation h6 Knight to f3 we have e six
and now Knight to e5 attacking crossings
bishop on g6 rush up to 87 and now comes
Bishop to d3 and here's a very nice
question for you why is and allowing
Carson to capture the d4 pawn what's the
idea behind allowing such a sacrifice in
the opening so you know if you're
interested feel free to pause the video
here and try to figure out why is Anand
allowing this I will give it a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
are able to solve this congratulations
you are an excellent player and for
those of you who just won't enjoy it so
the idea is if Queen captures on d4 then
comes Knight to f7 and now now you have
a problem just a second there 92 f7 and
there's really no good move here for
black if you capture the 19 captures
then of course you get Bishop to g6
check this opens up the attack to your
Queen the Queen and d4 is undefended
after we capture Bishop black loses the
Queen and of course the game another
thing after Knight captures on f7 even
if you don't capture even if you play
but should capture Sun d3 ad then comes
this variation nice captures rook so
grabbing the exchange Bishop to b4 check
Bishop blocks captures captures and now
Queen captures
unbe to attacking White's broken b1 rook
to d1 and now you can't really move the
bishop because you can't really allow
Queen to d8 of this will be checkmate as
the knight is covering f7 so you have to
go Queen to e5 check a white will block
and now this is the way you untangle
Queen captures Queen captures Bishop
captures King captures and after all is
said and done white is up the exchange
and black black has no compensation for
this exchange she does have one point
but that is not in
compensation so after this Bishop to d3
move of course not capturing only for a
rare Bishop captures on d3 is played
Queen captures on d3 and now Knight to
d7
we have f4 by Anand Bishop to b4 check
c3 and Bishop back to e7 and Bishop to
d2 now here Anand is offering the h4
pawn if Carson would capture here on h4
then on castles Queen side and White has
a huge lead in development and grabbing
this point simply doesn't doesn't
justify it
so after Bishop to d2 across and
develops a piece Knight G to f6 and here
we have a queenside castle and this is
the moment
Anand says that it was a really long
time since last he prepared for this
position and there is a known game where
unemployed Queen to e2 in this position
it was against ding Lyra in 2013 and
Anand won a very nice game against
England but here in this position he
played a queenside castle Carlsen
castled as well and now comes Knight to
e4 later well the next year here on and
will play a game against the vacant and
he will play a much better game with the
move Queen to f3 but here he played nice
to eat for and after Knight to e4 he
simply allows Carson to exchange pieces
too rapidly and and really equalized the
position here cousin played Knight
captures we have Queen captures and now
Knight captures on e5 pawn captures an
e5 and Queen to d5 cars cross and
immediately offers a trade of Queens and
once you do this there's really not
nothing to push for here if you if you
don't exchange Queens also notice the DA
to point is attacked and while you might
try something like Queen to g4 it
doesn't really work black will also have
a very nice equalizing ideas not
capturing an a2 immediately but first f5
attacking the Queen only after Queen to
g6 now you can capture on e2 and you can
even allow Bishop captures on h6
rook f7 defending checkmate and now
after g4 captures captures Bishop to f8
and black is completely fine but can now
even push on the Queen side himself
Bishop to e3 will also be an idea so
not nothing to hope for here with white
so after this Queen to d5 would have
Queen captures see capture Sun d5 and
now h5 we have b5 by Crossin now comes
rock to h3 a very nice idea
developing the rook now the rook will
also be useful on the Kings side and on
the Queen side both a 5 we have rope to
f1 rope to see it by cross and rope to
g3 now King to h7 and now rook G to f3
here by playing group G to f3
onon basically forces a row because
there is no useful move pretty much
cross and can make here if you try at 5
then rub the G Tris coming on and will
create a very nice outpost for this rook
it's a nice light course a look to g6 is
coming then the other rope can come to
g3 and it will be a very nice position
for Anand and on the other hand after
root G to f3 if you try f6 then simply
captures captures and after King to see
to defending the pawn c3 and King to d3
black will have no no useful ideas here
on only white can play this position for
a win so after up G to f3 cost and
pretty much forces Island pretty much
force forces draw and cross and simply
place King back to g8 we have R up to g3
King to h7 rook G to f3 and King to g8
so yeah this is this was game 2 of the
2013 World Chess Championship match
between Anna and Carson and the game 2
also ends in a draw so it seems the
players are still you know just testing
each other out you know who who brought
what to the table who prepared what and
you know still we'll take we'll take
some time for the further players to
really get into it here we said that we
do have one more photo but we saved it
after the game here is a photo from the
press conference you can see that
they're both enjoying themselves self so
far you know enjoying the match game -
pretty satisfactory for both of them
cousin said that he you know ok it's a
draw both of the games were drawn but he
also started the the the 2013 candidates
tournament that way
by drawing first a game against Kramnik
and then against iranian - two of the
top seed players so you know he doesn't
mind there are still at least 10 more
games and we'll see how it goes so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check the the press
conference in the description below also
there will be a link to some more photos
after round 2 and yeah as usual you can
check to my previous videos here think
all for watching and I will see you soon
with what most likely Game three of the
world 2013 World Chess Championship
match but also tomorrow the Louvin
tournament starts so perhaps we'll cover
some of the games from there as well
we'll see how it goes so thank you all
and I will see you soon